a final push by the highest authority in
the country
supreme leader ayatollah ali khamenei
made one last attempt
to rally the masses to the polling
stations on friday
the election is about the participation
of the people meaning the system
has the support of the people the future
of the country
in all aspects economics security
politics
is related to what you the people of
iran do on friday
his comments came on the same day the
only reformist candidate
alizadeh dropped out of the race in a
letter to the interior minister
alizadeh told of his decision but
without stating the reason
or whether he would now be backing
another candidate
in a statement former nuclear negotiator
saeed jaleeli
also left the race endorsing
conservative candidate and the current
head of iran's judiciary ibrahim raici
another conservative candidate and
member of parliament ali raza zakhani
from rome
is also out he says he believes ibrahim
raisi is a more suitable candidate to
become iran's eighth president
during his weekly cabinet meeting on
wednesday president hassan rouhani laid
out the realities of this election
there have been some injustices during
the campaign but we should all oblige
ourselves and make up for them if we can
we might want some individuals who are
not among the candidates
but we have to choose the ones closest
to who we want
if the masses don't participate neither
the country or the people will benefit
voter turnout continues to be a major
concern for officials here
due to covet restrictions and voter
apathy non-official polls suggest this
election
could see the lowest voter turnout since
the revolution of 1979.
the remaining candidates have been
sending out text messages to the public
urging them to vote despite three rounds
of live debates on state tv there's been
very little campaigning on the streets
here
a high voter turnout is important
because it is directly associated
with the approval of the establishment
dorsal jabari al-jazeera tehran